mus grün Seite
drin
so das ist erotische Dynamik hier
herrlich wir haben pass auf ich muss es
ist wieder Zeit unser nächster Gast
steht auf dem Plan du kennst ja ich k
auch f
unterschrieben
dasti habe ich das richtig
ausgesprochen und jetzt K wier Fragen
stellchch das muss muss
auch mus andere Sprache perfekt len nur
die
eigene
lateinin so pass auf jetzt geht's darum
de ihr könnt wieder Fragen stellen das
hmer wie bei Dir ja ist do super W man
so Fragen gestellt bekommt Hammer oder
und K Fragen stellen guck und den
Infotext und dann ladet hoch was das
Zeug hält und seid fragt ihn warum hat
der Haare am Rücken warum hat er Haare
am Fuß warum hat er überhaupt Haare
warum haben wir überhaupt alle Haare ne
warum habe ich Haare ne warum gibt das
überhaupt Haare wie wird haareare
geschrieben das Wort Hamburg Harburg ne
haburg es
ist so also ja und dann habt ihr so viel
Spaß wie Mozart mit den Fragen und die
und so weiter und so noch Wort an unsere
lieben Zuschauer von dir chateauon
chateauon arci click Zoom forever ich
ich muss jetzt pissen aber nicht auf
mich bitte natürlich nicht auf Dich auf
ihn